Alejandro Galvez is trying to make
enough to cover one day's expenses
selling secondhand electrical goods on
the street it's illegal but he has
little choice I thought the policeman
yesterday please sir let us work because
it's going to get worse if we can't sell
now we'll have to go out and steal later
they say there's nothing worse than
kicking someone when they're down
and that's exactly what Kovac 19 is
doing to Latin America I was a waiter
but all the restaurants closed so now
I'm trying to survive doing this just to
pay the rent the pandemic caught the
region on an already poor footing with
anemic economic growth rising crime and
social unrest fanned by severe
inequality the forecast now is even more
bleak poverty will increase in very
outstanding ways I mean with extreme
poverty we'll go up to 82 million people
so and probably extreme poverty will go
up to 210 million people and of course
if people lose ten percent of their
income even these figures will go higher
the biggest problem is unemployment and
many Latin American countries are too
insolvent to provide viable economic
rescue plans for small and medium-sized
businesses Venezuela Ecuador Argentina
and most of Central America are deep in
debt already but all without exception
will have a hard time keeping their
heads above water even after the
pandemic subsides between 1995 and 2015
tens of millions of Latin Americans rose
from poverty and into the lower middle
class many of them were able to buy
apartments like the ones you see here
now these are precisely the people who
stand to lose everything
the IMF predicts the region will suffer
its worst recession in half a century a
lot may depend on if and when Latin
America's main trading partners China
the US and Europe recover nothing is
certain at this point except the
region's main weakness a structural
inequality that will take much longer to
cure than the pandemic Lucia Newman al
Jazeera Santiago